speaking of liars let's finish up with
the infallible fouchy
so he now wants children over two years
old
to mask up or take the vaccine no
children
are dying because of this thing it is
extraordinary
extraordinarily rare adults even it's
about 97.5 to 99
that you will survive if you get coveted
you all know the stuff about the
comorbidities
and being overweight and diabetes and
everything else on top of the fact that
now many of us have had covet and have
natural antibodies
and a huge amount of people have now
been vaccinated and we're supposed to
believe that the vaccines work although
now they're telling us
people are going to have to get booster
shots every year and everything else
well now
fauci wants kids i mean really think
before you watch this video
whatever whatever little child you know
in your life i just spent some time with
my sister
and her great kids she's got a six year
old and a two-year-old
this two-year-old boy like this is not a
kid who should be wearing a mess this is
a kid who should be running free and
playing with blocks and destroying stuff
and going crazy and
running around his house in a scooter
which mom wasn't thrilled about but you
know what are you gonna do
anyway here's lord fauci you know the
children under the age of 12
who are not eligible for the vaccines
generally do not
get sick don't get coveted or don't get
us ill with it
but what does this spread of the delta
variant mean for them
for the children under the age of 12 and
what's the timeline for when they might
become
eligible well a couple of questions and
the answers are
the children who are not able to get
vaccinated because of their age
should follow their parents should
follow with them the guidelines
of the cdc that unvaccinated children of
a certain age greater than two years old
should be wearing
masks no doubt about that that's the way
to protect them from getting infected
because if they do
they can then spread the infection to
someone else
so the cdc guidelines for unvaccinated
people including children
are not changed at all we are currently
doing we being the federal
government together in collaboration
with the pharmaceutical companies
age de-escalation studies namely looking
at
the safety and the immunogenicity of
vaccines
in children from 12 to 9 years old then
from 9 to 6
then from 6 to 2 years old and then
ultimately
from 6 months to 2 years old
dystopia man we live in a
modern dystopia that really is the truth
okay so a couple things here first off
andrea mitchell
uh that's msnbc by the way andrea
mitchell she says something interesting
at the beginning she basically says kids
don't get sick and then in the next
breath she goes when can the kids get
vaccinated
she links that then to the delta variant
she doesn't give you any data
on the delta variant right nothing and
this is what they do with everything
they don't give you any data points
they just say things so she goes kids
don't get sick when can they all get
vaccinated because of delta and it's
like well well is something going on
with delta that we need to know is it
killing a lot of kids
then they're saying if they get this is
what
fauci saying he's saying if they get
infected meaning the kids
they can spread it now that's probably
true right like
it is possible that kids uh can get
covet actually my
six-year-old niece and my two-year-old
nephew who i just mentioned they had
coveted they did the quarantine the
whole thing they were sick for a few
days and then
everything was okay my sister got it
when they got it and actually my
brother-in-law who lived in a very small
house with them did not get it
these are all just things like i'm just
putting out a little bit of
a little bit of personal stuff right
there but the point is
okay let's say a two-year-old got it it
might give it to another two-year-old
and another two or another two
but is there any evidence that those
kids are gonna die is there any
they're gonna have long-term effects or
anything else notice they don't tell you
any of those things
so his answer is let's do these studies
to inject
two-year-olds with this stuff and in the
meantime
follow the cdc guidelines that have been
completely all over the map and often
contradictory and everything else
um or put your kids in masks
so two-year-olds and three-year-olds and
everything else should be in masks you
know i was in
uh universal studios we took my my niece
and nephew to universal studios about a
week and a half ago
uh here in uh los angeles and i would
say half the kids there were in masks
so you got kids walking into harry
potter land kids on
outdoor roller coasters kids that should
be
laughing and smiling and running around
and it's la in the summer it was like 95
degrees
everyone's dripping with sweat you've
got adults who i guess have been
vaccinated not in mass
and you've got kids who are dressed up
as harry potter
or hermione whatever her name is and
whoever and those are heavy costumes
that they're wearing dressed up as
wizards hermione granger thank you
um you know i'm a star wars guy more of
a robot guy than the wizards it's a
little ah the wizards whatever
oh you got a little stick and you can
fly on a broom zippity-doodle it's like
give me a lightsaber all right but
but the point is they're ruining
children they're ruining children
fauci is just ridiculous i i can't
believe that biden's my president and
fauci is my chief medical
officer like what is going on here what
is going on here